Hi, this channel is about the risks of
advanced AI and the safety research that
people are doing to mitigate those
risks. And sometimes when people hear
that, they say to me, "But Rob,
technology is good." People are always
scared of new technology, usually for
pretty bad reasons.
>> Technology.
>> Oh my god.
>> And their safety concerns slow new
technologies down. So why are you
worried about AI risks? Don't you
realize that technology is good? And the
thing about this is it's true.
Technology is good. and fears about new
technology usually are misplaced. I
think advanced AI may be an exception to
the rule. Can you guess why? But the
rule itself is very real and very
important to me. I'm pretty much always
on that side of these kinds of debates
and have been for a long time. In fact,
I'm probably more pro technology than
most of the people who criticize me on
this. Like, okay, I try not to give
political opinions outside of my direct
area of expertise, but since you asked,
I think we should probably abolish the
FDA and replace it with something that
doesn't slow down medical progress so
much. The current policy is effectively
all new medicine is banned by default,
which is pretty wild if you think about
it. Obviously, you need rules and
regulations about medicine. And I'm not
an expert. I'm not going to claim to
know exactly what system would work
best. But my point is, I think safety
concerns are slowing down medical
progress too much, and we should
prioritize that more. We should probably
also relax research ethics a bit. Like,
for example, we should have way more
human challenge trials. We'd get new
treatments much quicker. I also think
the commercial aerospace industry is too
conservative because of safety concerns.
Airplanes are extremely safe relative to
basically any other form of transport,
which is great, but like we could have
had supersonic passenger aircraft years
ago. I mean, practical, economically
viable supersonic passenger aircraft.
Instead, we kind of went backwards.
Hopefully, that's changing soon. And we
could have built enough nuclear power to
be basically done with fossil fuel power
generation decades ago as well, but
nuclear power is held back by safety
concerns in most of the world. So, we're
still burning coal, which releases more
harmful radiation per kilowatt hour than
nuclear does. Same thing with
self-driving cars. They're already safer
than human drivers who kill about a
million people every year. Each year
that we delay these kinds of things
effectively kills a large number of
people. It doesn't make sense to delay
them for safety reasons. I want a cure
for cancer, a self-driving car powered
by cheap nuclear energy and a jetpack.
Damn it.
Okay. Well, the jetpack might actually
be unsafe, but the rest would be good.
Technology is good. Technology is the
main cause of the enormous improvements
in living standards that we've achieved
throughout history. And I mean, just
look at it. Look at how cool this is.
Obviously, technology is good, right?
Well, of course, this is not obvious to
everyone, so we should probably make an
actual argument. Why is technology good?
Like, if you think about it, it is a bit
strange to be able to say that something
as broad as technology is good.
Technology is a huge range of stuff,
including good and bad. Why should we
expect such a wide range of things to be
good overall? This actually is not
obvious. My answer is technology is good
because people are good. Now, if you
don't think people are good, I'm sorry,
but this is a staunchly pro-humanity
channel. If that bothers you, you can
leave. You're very welcome to stay
though either way because you're a
person and therefore probably good. But
yeah, technology is good because people
are good. Technology enables people to
do new things. It gives them new options
and new capabilities. People use those
new capabilities to do what they want,
to get more of what they want. Since
most people are basically good and
mostly want good things, people being
able to do more stuff to get what they
want ends up being good overall. In
fact, allowing people to get what they
want is a very important principle,
which you may also know by the name
freedom.
If you want to stop someone from getting
what they want, you'd better have a good
reason. And the same applies to standing
in the way of a new technology. Of
course, sometimes some relatively small
number of people want something bad and
use technology to get it, right? New
technology can be misused, but most
people are good and people who want to
do harm tend to be outnumbered and
outgunned. Often a bigger problem is
unintended side effects or accidents.
These can be pretty bad, but the
technology is often still overall worth
it. And we can deal with problems as
they arise. And usually these problems
are dealt with not by trying to go
backwards, but by new and better
technology. Okay, so if I think that
technology is good and is too often
slowed down by safety concerns, what am
I doing running a channel about my AI
safety concerns? Why is AI any different
from other technology? The answer is it
isn't really. Or rather, it isn't yet,
but it will be sooner or later for a few
reasons. Firstly, advanced
generalpurpose artificial intelligence
is the first technology that can
function as a capable independent agent
with its own goals. As I said, the
reason technology is good is because
it's a tool to get people what they
want. But, and this is important because
this makes AGI fundamentally different
from all previous technology in history.
Once you have AI systems intelligently
pursuing their own goals, you have the
first ever technology which isn't just
about enabling people to get what they
want, but about the technology itself
getting what it wants. And what does it
want? Well, it would be cool if we had
some reliable way of knowing that or
updating it or making sure it's what we
intended. Technology is good. AI will be
different. And that difference has a lot
of effects. Perhaps most importantly,
the normal methods we use for other
technology, where we deal with each new
problem as it comes up just aren't up to
the task of dealing with AGI by default.
Advanced AI can hide problems from us,
manipulate us, and interfere with our
attempts to fix things. Our standard
safety methods and societal processes
are not set up to deal with
technological systems that can
intelligently act against us. Like, we
invented CFCs. They made a hole in the
ozone layer. We developed new
refrigerants that didn't have that
problem and mandated their use. And now
the ozone hole is closing. CFC's weren't
able to hide the hole in the ozone layer
or pin the blame on some other kind of
molecule. CFCs are just simple chemical
compounds. Similarly, we invented
planes. They crashed. We figured out why
and improved the technology. They
crashed again. We fixed those problems.
They crashed again. We repeated this and
honestly kind of embarrassingly large
number of times. And now planes are
extremely safe. But planes aren't able
to notice when they're being tested and
behave differently to make sure they
pass the tests so that they can make
sure to crash only when they're carrying
real passengers. None of the people
involved wants that. And planes are just
tools. In the same way, we invented
nuclear power. We had Chernobyl and 3M
Island. We improved the technology and
now nuclear power is much safer than
fossil fuels and should have been
powering everything for a while now. But
nuclear power plants aren't able to
carefully observe our safety protocols
in order to decide the best way to melt
down and the best time to do it so that
it's least likely to be contained. Power
plants aren't agents. AGI is different
from all other technology. And notice
how in all of those examples, the hazard
did have to actually happen, often
several times, and we responded to it
after that. We did have a nuclear power
plant actually melt down. We did have a
ton of planes actually crash and kill
real people. and we fixed the problems
once they'd already happened. AGI may
not give us so many chances. The regular
approach where you have the full-blown
form of the hazard happen and then you
learn from it, that only works if the
hazard is recoverable. AGI risks are not
necessarily recoverable. If we lose
control of the world, we've lost it
permanently. We shouldn't expect to be
able to get it back from an intelligent
adversary. Has humanity ever managed to
rein in a large-scale risk before the
full-blown form of the hazard has
actually happened at least once? Kind of
with nuclear weapons. We had some very
close calls, but we've so far just about
managed to avoid having a global
thermonuclear war. How did we achieve
that? Well, we developed the new
technology. We saw that a potentially
unreoverable outcome was possible. And
then we freaked out and did
unprecedented things to prevent it from
happening. In that case, humanity
correctly recognized that there are
certain risks that you can't have happen
even once because they're not
recoverable. We can have a pretty big
global pandemic and come back from it.
We can even come back from a
medium-sized nuclear exchange. But we
can't have AI take over the world one
time, say, "Oops, figure out what went
wrong, learn from our mistake, and move
on. Once we lose, we've lost." We can't
be driven extinct and then patch the
issue in the next release. Technology is
good and it usually shouldn't be slowed
down too much by safety concerns. This
is true of technology broadly, including
almost all AI technology up until this
point. But advanced artificial general
intelligence will be categorically
different from every other technology in
history. And we need to recognize that
and act accordingly.
[Music]
Hey, do you know about AI.info? It's
this great website that grew out of my
Discord server. It's awesome. They've
got answers to hundreds of the most
common questions about AI safety.
There's even a chatbot you can talk to.
It's very cool and it's a great place to
send new people. AIsafety.info. Check it
out. Also, if you're looking to help
out, they do pretty urgently need
funding to keep the thing running.
Speaking of which, I'm kept running by
my wonderful patrons, all of these
amazing people here. Thank you all so
much. In this video, I'm especially
thanking Allied Toasters. So, thank you,
Allied Toasters, and thank you all for
watching. I'll see you next time.
[Music]